it's hard to talk about this stuff
without coming off too angry i don't
want to come off angry or anti-man i'm
not i'm engaged to a man i'm going to
marry a man
i mean
we'll see
i love him very much but when we talk
about this stuff sometimes the
conversations get awkward because he
hasn't had a lot of trauma in his life
we have a very different definition of
the concept of trauma and sometimes it
makes our conversations weird one time
we were talking about bad things that
had happened to us in our childhoods and
i'm going on and on and on and on
[Music]
he cuts me off he goes you know
something really messed up happened to
me when i was five
and i was like oh my god baby what
happened
he goes when i was five i woke up on
christmas eve and i saw my dad wrapping
gifts
and i was like and then he fucked you
[Applause]
he was like that's when i found out
there's no santa claus
oh okay oh that's that's your definition
of struggle you thought one guy was
giving you presents and then you found
out another guy was giving you the exact
same presents
you realize girls are thrilled when we
find out there's no santa claus we're
like oh thank god i have to sit on that
weirdos lap at the mall
i always thought that was sketchy